ما المدى الذي يمكن ان تؤثر به عمليه
اغتيال العاروري على اداء المقاومه في
تقديرك لا في تقديري لن تتاثر المقاومه
هذا يعني نابع من السياق التاريخي
للاغتيالات الاسرائيليه اسرائيل اغتالت
اغلب قيادات الشعب الفلسطيني اغتالت احمد
ياسين اغتالت ابو محمد الجعبري اغتالت
يحيى عياس
ياسر فتح اثر المقاومه ربما بعد ساعات
يعلن من هو مسؤول ملف الضفه الغربيه في
المكتب السياسي هكذا عودتنا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والفصائل الفلسطينيه طوال
الثوره الفلسطينيه لذلك فكره تحييد قيادي
هنا او هناك على سبيل المثال تم اغتيال
مسؤول لواء شمال قطاع غزه ابو انس الغندور
بعد الدقائق كان هناك قائد للواء ربما
اكثر صرامه وصعوبه في ادائه من ابو انس
الغندور وبذلك التجارب تدلل ان فكره تحييد
الشخصيات الكبيره فكره فقط لها بعد معنوي
اكثر من انها لها بعد على الارض او تاثير
على الارض حتى لو اغتالوا السنوار او
الضيف في تقدير الكل انه المقاومه ستبقى
مقاومه كفكره في مواجهه هذا الاحتلال وهذه
العقده التي يعاني منها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كم من الشخصيات تم اغتيالها
سواء سياسيه او عسكريه او غير ذلك لم تؤثر
كثيرا على اداء المقاومه وفي لحظه ما كون
ان المقاومه هي مؤسسه و تحديدا حركه حماس
تضبطها مؤسسه هناك قائد ونائب للقائد
ونائب لنائب القائد وبذلك في حال اي شخص
ذهب يتم شغر هذا المكان بشكل كامل ولن
تتاثر المقاومه لكن الدلالات السياسيه
والبعد النفسي والمعنوي هو الاساس في هذه
الموضوع بالتاكيد رحيل شخصيه بوزن صالح
العاروري يعني وزن كبير بالتاكيد سيكون له
اثار على الشارع الفلسطيني هناك صدمه هناك
حزن في الشارع الفلسطيني وهناك نشوه يعني
ارادها نتنياهو ان يحقق هذه النشوه لدى
النخب الاسرائيليه كما يغردون الان على
تويتر وعلى غيره من المواقع في تقدير هذه
النشوه سرعان ما تزول عندما يكون القرار
الحكيم في تبني السيناريو الامثل للرد على
صالح على اغتيال صالح العروي كون ان سماحه
الشيخ حسن نصر الله الامين العام لحزب
الله قطع وعدا وهذا الوعد هو ان اي مساس
باي شخصيه عربيه لبنانيه فلسطينيه من
لبنان سيكون الرد كبير وهذا يطرح
السيناريوهات ماذا سيكون خطاب السماحه
الشيخ غدا ولماذا لم يؤجل هذا الخطاب في
تقديري ان في ذلك ربما نطرح في سياق هذه
الحلقه ما هي السيناريوهات التي قد
يتبناها سماحه الشيخ الى اي مسار يسير هل
الى الصبر الاستراتيجي الذي دعا له الشيخ
صالح العاروري كثيرا ان بضروره تبنيه
وتبنته المقاومه عندما تم اغتيال ثلاثه من
قياده الجهاد الاسلامي ام الرد المتكافئ
ام الرد الامني حتى اللحظه نستطيع ان
نستشرف اي من هذه السيناريوهات بعد خطاب
السيد حسن نصغ